the Austria and the nursing Union is
talking about expanding its strike
action from a e intensive care and
cancer Wars they could also join strikes
too do you support them expanding their
action
well first of all the RCN and the nurses
have never taken industrial action ever
before so I think that context is really
important and the leader of the RCN has
made it clear the government have just
absolutely Point Blank refused to
negotiate with them and I think that
we're in this situation because the
government are acting in a hostile way
towards these workers that kept us going
through the pandemic and they really
urgently need to get around the table no
nurse wants to take industrial action
and cause
um you know disruption to the care that
they provide but of course we've seen
record numbers of vacancies in nursing
care and therefore their jobs are
becoming increasingly difficult because
of Staff shortages and because of the
conditions in which those nurses are
trying to do their job so without this
intervention without the government
getting around the table these issues
are ongoing regardless of the strike
because we can't carry on as things are
are you concerned about patient safety
though if nurses were to expand their
strike action to a e intensive care and
cancer Awards and what would your
message be to someone whose care could
be affected by these strikes
well we've we've seen increases in
waiting times for people cancer patients
and others who are on waiting list of of
increased under the conservative
government and without this intervention
and without the government getting
behind the table and dealing with the
concerns that these nurses are facing
every single day unfortunately we have a
situation where patients lives are at
risk because of the crisis in our NHS
and therefore they have to get round the
table and deal with these issues they
know what the issues are the government
do they know there's a crisis in our
Recruitment and Retention of NHS staff
and nurses and therefore it's it's
completely unacceptable that they're not
willing to speak to the nurses and get
around the table the nurses do not want
to take industrial action it's the first
time they've ever taken industrial
action in their history and therefore
that tells you the difficulties that
they're under the immense pressure that
those nurses are under and I think most
of the public can recognize that and can
recognize that the government are
refusing to negotiate shape and deal
with the crisis that they've inflicted
Upon Our NHS staff
we're treating the shadow Health
secretary says the NHS is not a shrine
do you agree
well it isn't but it's incredibly
important to the British people you know
the labor Party founded the NHS and the
principles of the NHS free at the point
of views is really important and people
have come to treasure the fact and they
understand the importance of having that
situation where when you're are in
crisis when you have a medical emergency
you can get the care and your loved one
can get the care that they need
unfortunately what we're seeing at the
moment is people can't access ambulances
because of the pressure they're under
they can't get appointments to see their
GP they can't get appointments for
cancer treatment at the earliest
opportunity because of the situation and
the crisis that we've seen in the NHS
and some of that is down to the
situation that nurses and our NHS staff
are facing we've got a recruitment and
retention and a Workforce problem and
that Consultants Specialists will tell
you that that is a real issue for NHS
staff which is adding further pressure
so unless the government are willing to
get around the table and have a strategy
for the workforce as labor has then
we're not going to see a resolution to
this and the industrial action is part
of an accumulation of that crisis of the
NHS staff saying please help us do our
job we want to protect people we want to
look after them but they're not able to
do that at the moment because of this
government
one week on from the earthquakes that
have struck Syria and turkey real
concern about Aid getting into Syria at
the moment the U.S has talked about
easing some sanctions on Syria to help
the passage of Aid would you back the UK
taking a similar line
we need to work with the UN and make
sure that we're able to open up those
corridors to get that support to the
Syrian people it's absolutely
devastating to see what's happened in
turkey and Syria and the thousands of
lives that have been lost and every hour
that goes by where those corridors were
not open people are dying and people are
not getting the support they need so I
absolutely buckles working with the UN
to ensure that those corridors of Aid
can get there and we can support people
in what is a humanitarian and tragic
crisis that we're seeing unfolding in
that area and we need to get onto that
ASAP so that people can get the support
they need well yes and support so badly
needed the government dropped its
International Aid budget from 0.7 of GDP
to 0.5 percent in the aftermath of the
pandemic will labor commit to putting it
back up to 0.7 percent
we have committed to to increasing the
overseas aid budget and it's really
important that that work that we do
internationally is not only about how we
deliver aid but it's also about our soft
power internationally in terms of
working with our allies and developing
our values across the globe so it is
really crucial and very short-sighted of
the government to cut that a budget and
we think that it should be reinstated
but you know the situation that we face
at the moment in Syria is so dire that
the UN need to get together as quickly
as possible and to make sure those
corridors of Aid gets there and I want
to also pay tribute to those people in
the UK emergency services our Rescue
Services that are over in the region at
the moment that are supporting those
efforts and to continue to coordinate
those efforts internationally
the defense secretary are saying today
that the the UK is going to conduct a
review into its own security after a
fourth object has been shot out of the
Skies over North America How concerned
are you about Chinese spy balloons
well I think National Security has got
to be an absolute Paramount to us and I
welcome that the defense secretary has
said that they're going to review it in
light of what's Happening you know we
have to work with our International
allies and that the US were absolutely
right to take the action they took as
well as Canada and we have to remain
Vigilant you know and ensure that our
military services and our security
services have the support they need to
deliver and we have to pay play an
international role in that and remain
Vigilant so yes we should be constantly
reviewing our security and ensuring that
our security services have the support
they need and the resources to do their
job effectively
and I know today um labor is talking a
lot about waste on government
procurement cards government credit
cards if you like
um tell us what the figures are because
I was speaking to the government
Minister Richard Holden earlier on and
he said according to his figures
spending has come down on the cards
since labor was in power he said 995
million was spent on the cards in 2009
and last year it was around 150 million
so can you clear up what you're saying
today
sure Richard is confusing what happened
in 2009 was the procurement cards were
used by other public sector
organizations local government the NHS
and the BBC we're talking about
Whitehall use of
um credit cards and that is extremely
increased under this government and
there was a National Audit office report
and the Public Accounts report years ago
that was very clear to the conservative
government that the use of these cards
needs to be transparent that they need
to be regulated and that they shouldn't
be excessive and yet we've seen
thousands of pounds spent on Art we've
seen thousands of pounds on a hot pink
photo booth for a showing of um a film
these are not what I would consider a
cost of living crisis appropriate use of
that spend of course we need credit
cards for emergencies but there you
should be transparent and they should be
appropriate
your pleasure to bring in an office of
value for money to sort it out isn't
that going to be expensive in itself and
introduce more red tape and bureaucracy
no because we're pulling together a
number of
um organizations at the moment another a
number of areas where they that can be
used to set up the office for value for
money so it would be cost neutral but
not only that the work that they will
carry out will save money in making sure
that the government is acting in a lean
way we've seen Scandal and we've seen
sleaze we've seen billions of pounds
wasted under the conservative government
that we have now and no action to clear
up this mess we've been very clear that
we've set up an ethics and integrity
commission that's independent that can
look into these issues and can ensure
it's regulated and our office for value
for money will ensure that every pound
of taxpayers money is spent they're
getting the best out of that money and
then it's not being wasted and these
credit cards are a way of bypassing the
normal order in process and we're seeing
you know when it comes to the end of the
financial Year big jumps in the spend
and we're seeing expenditure which is
just not justifiable during the cost of
living crisis so there has to be
transparency and there has to be
regulation of the use of these cards